[Music]
would you eat nothing but oatmeal paste
for weeks on end how about one apple
just one per day crazy diets intense
exercise here's how these actors lost
insane amounts of weight for a movie
role
the machinist is a hard watch especially
when you think about how much weight
christian bale had to lose to play the
psychologically troubled factory worker
trevor resnick bale is a master of yo-yo
dieting and physical transformation he
piled on the pounds for american hustle
and put on some serious muscle for the
dark knight trilogy still he has never
surpassed the weight shedding alchemy he
wove in director brad anderson's 2004
thriller as bale prowls around the
screen looking undernourished and in
dire need of some kfc the physical
manifestation of his character's
troubled mind is unnerving bill lost a
whopping 63 pounds for the role in just
four months according to men's health
bale got in shape or out of it through a
strict diet of black coffee a single
apple and a lonely can of tuna per day
you probably won't be surprised to learn
that that's extremely stressful to the
body and detrimental to the metabolism
health expert daniel o'shaughnessy
explained this is less than 200 calories
per day so it's not healthy at all after
15 years of shifting body types bale now
seems to concur with the medical
consensus he revealed to the sunday
times that after gorging on
cheeseburgers and donuts to play the
pot-bellied dick cheney in 2018's vice
his days of dramatic transformations
were over bale explained i can't keep
doing it i really can't my mortality is
staring me in the face
as a press photographer who specializes
in snapping shots of traffic accidents
home invasions murder scenes and house
fires blue bloom and nightcrawler has a
big appetite but not for savory snacks
or sugary treats jake gyllenhaal plays
the unethical snapper who finds himself
consumed by the public's demand for
unethical journalism bloom has an
insatiable appetite to be the first at
the scene for a big scoop even if it
means he has to manipulate events to get
what he craves nightcrawler is a classic
study on how insidious corruption is all
of bloom's nervous energy appears to eat
away at him in his frantic bid to stay
one step ahead gyllenhaal said to us
weekly about his character i knew that
lou was literally and figuratively
hungry that's why the actor took 30
pounds off his typically toned physique
to give his character the gaunt hagrid
and haunted look of a coyote all bones
and sunken eyes gyllenhaal's
transformation helped give bloom a
tangible air of gnaring regret and
wasted decadence even though he stuck to
a special diet of protein carbs and fats
for his role in disney's prince of
persia gyllenhaal revealed that he
adopted no special dietary regime for
nightcrawler just one of enforced hunger
he explained to variety i would try to
eat as few calories as possible i knew
if i was hungry that i was in the right
spot physically it showed itself but
chemically and mentally i think it was
even a more fascinating journey it
became a struggle for me
unless you're trained extensively in the
art of survival the one thing you're
going to do when stranded on a desert
island is starve or at least lose a
little weight that's exactly what
happens to tom hanks's character chuck
nolan and robert zemeckis's castaway to
be fair hanks really had no choice but
to slim down if he wanted to play the
role of a fedex executive who finds
himself the sole survivor of a plane
crash when you're washed up on an
uninhabited island in the middle of the
pacific ocean with only a volleyball
named wilson to keep you company it
tends to take a physical toll hanks took
a year out from filming the movie's
initial scenes to shed 55 pounds and
ensure his character's predicament
looked plausible slimming down to 170
pounds from 225 wasn't a walk in the
park for hayes he was counting calories
for a whole year and had to give up a
lot of comfort food including his
favorite french fries yet there was one
thing hanks was adamant about not giving
up he told entertainment tonight the
only thing i did not give up was coffee
nope wasn't about to can't do it excuse
me no i'm not ain't gonna happen pal
charged with a regular caffeine intake
hank's diet featured few carbs and a lot
of vegetables he was also allowed a
little fish and was given plenty of
coconut milk
take much more of those coconuts
coconut milk is a natural laxative
dropping 55 pounds for castaway wasn't
tom hanks's first weight loss rodeo back
in 1993 the actor lost 26 pounds and won
his first oscar for his compelling
performance as aids patient andrew
beckett in jonathan demise philadelphia
with philadelphia being one of the first
mainstream hollywood films to tackle the
crisis of aids and homophobia hanks's
role was guaranteed to come under
scrutiny the ravages of the disease
needed to be visible and not underplayed
in any form so hanks adopted a strict
weight loss program to do the role
justice hanks went into detail about
shedding the pounds at a sleepless in
seattle press junket explaining the
physical regimen was very much dictated
by the reality of the science so i was
on a diet and exercise program and took
a lot of stuff hanks revealed that he
had a pair of sports doctors who
provided him with prescribed meals and
ensured he'd work out every day without
fail combined with the makeup hair loss
and hanks's acting chops the weight loss
helped to create a convincing heir of
someone at death's door two decades
later in 2013 hanks confessed at a press
conference that his long-term habit of
gaining and losing weight for film roles
might have contributed to his diagnosis
of type 2 diabetes he said you know
those high blood sugar numbers you've
been dealing with since you were 36 well
you've graduated
strange things happen at sea and rapid
weight loss can be one of them in
director ron howard's 2015 homage to
moby dick chris hemsworth plays whaling
veteran owen chase capsized by a massive
whale and washed up on a tiny island
chasing the remainder of his crew waste
away to almost nothing until the spectra
of cannibalism rears its ugly head
obviously to get to a point where eating
each other is an option the men can't
exactly appear like they've been living
on a steady diet of steak dinners and
protein shakes so what's an actor famous
for playing a muscled up thunder god
like thor to do lose weight by fasting
with a 500 calorie a day diet hemsworth
dropped 33 pounds for his role in in the
heart of the sea and it only took him
and his co-stars a month to trim the fat
it's not an experience he would
recommend though he told the daily mail
we couldn't go away for a month and get
skinny we had to do it while we were
shooting i reckon about 90 percent of
our conversations were about our
favorite foods and what we would eat
when we finished the film
the whole time
diminishing your calorie intake and
getting hungrier and moodier and
more unpleasant to be around
so what exactly did hemsworth and his
acting buddies chow down on while
filming hemsworth told men's health that
there was a lot of vegetable soup and
salad he added at one point a day's
rations were a boiled egg a couple of
crackers and a celery stick we can only
imagine his reaction at seeing a full
mill for the first time after filming so
i live and breathe
he's mine
if a filmmaker like martin scorsese asks
you to lose weight for a film he's
dreamed about making for years you would
be a foolhardy thespian indeed to refuse
thankfully adam driver was not that
actor and obligingly lost 50 pounds for
his role as francisco garupe in
scorsese's long-awaited movie silence
playing a 17th century portuguese jesuit
priest alongside andrew garfield driver
journeys to japan in search of his
missing mentor driver's character is far
from properly nourished at the start of
the film but as the plot progresses he
and his companion become increasingly
thin driver told interview when the
movie begins the characters have been
traveling for two years there's disease
and a shortage of food they're already
kind of depleted and then we continue to
lose weight driver revealed that
scorsese wanted the actors to help the
story physically by looking emaciated to
play the part of a persecuted priest
with conviction driver lost 30 pounds
before production began and a further 20
pounds while filming what did you lose
uh 50 51 pounds that's like come on yeah
what was left of you yeah not a lot just
pure rage
in an interview with esquire driver went
into more detail about his diet saying
it's coffee all day that's a given a
shake in the morning then a protein and
vegetable at night if you need energy
you chew these fiber gummies
driver also recalled one particular
occasion in which he and garfield had to
wait on a boat while everyone else on
set ate dumplings on the shore when
driver voiced his displeasure scorsese
simply laughed and said sucks to be you
if there's anything mahatma gandhi is
known for apart from peace understanding
and that facebook quote about being the
change you wish to see it's his slender
frame hunger strikes and vegetarianism
for ben kingsley whose father is of
indian descent shaving his head growing
a mustache and rocking a pair of round
glasses wasn't enough to do the road
justice that's why he decided to give up
meat and dropped 20 pounds according to
the new york times sir richard
attenborough had been striving for two
decades to find the right actor for his
biopic when he chose kingsley the actor
did everything humanly possible to
render his portrayal impeccable
scrutinizing old newsreel footage
pouring over biographies and diligently
searching out photos of gandhi became
something of an obsession for kingsley
as the kind of actor who always tries to
push boundaries kingsley felt compelled
to go vegetarian and rigorously meditate
during his free time he explained the
preparation is entirely systematic
practical and scientific but when i play
the role whether it is hamlet or gandhi
some other kind of information comes to
the forefront a certain energy is
released in the absence of any other
strict dietary regime contemplating
existence itself and abstaining from
meat were enough for kingsley to lose a
considerable amount of mass
when playing a professional ballerina
getting ready for an upcoming production
of tchaikovsky's swan lake there are
certain standards one must adhere to and
having almost zero body fat is one of
them for darren aronofsky's black swan
natalie portman dropped 20 pounds to
play the part of a skeletal ballet
dancer cast to play the titular role it
was certainly a challenge as portman
revealed to entertainment weekly there
were some nights that i thought i
literally was going to die it was the
first time i understood how you could
get so wrapped up in a role that it
could sort of take you down the
independent reported that portman's
punishing diet consisted of little more
than carrots and almonds as she spent a
grueling eight hours a day rehearsing
despite taking home the best actress
oscar for her role not everyone was
happy with portman's portrayal of a
neurotic ballerina rachel prince of
ballet british columbia said she's
anorexic bulimic crazy i'm sure every
dancer struggles with little things here
and there but for one girl to struggle
with every single problem out there it
just makes us look crazy the daily mail
reported that portman's co-star mila
kunis also lost 20 pounds for her role
and went on a binge eating spree
post-production kunis joked it took me 5
months to lose 20 pounds and it took me
hours to gain it back
chris pratt may not look exactly scrawny
as star-lord in james gunn's guardians
of the galaxy but the actors still lost
60 pounds in six months to play the
disco loving leader of a gang of
extraterrestrial criminals to get in
shape pratt relied less on a strict diet
and more on consistent exercise
according to men's journal the actor
teamed up with a pair of personal
trainers who revamped his diet and
boosted his daily intake to 4 000
calories committing himself to a fierce
regimen that included swimming running
kickboxing boxing and even a triathlon
pratt whipped himself into shape of
course he had to sacrifice one
particular vice to maintain his new bod
beer so the only thing you did was stop
drinking beer yeah i lost 50 pounds in
one month
how much beer were you drinking i know
right pratt's delayed well of course
steak chicken eggs fish and vegetables
were all on the menu but if it came out
of a frying pan it wasn't going on his
plate complex carbs such as oats brown
rice and potatoes were given the green
light as were plenty of vitamins and
supplements pratt a fierce believer in
working out and eating well told men's
health if you cut the crap out of your
diet and spend an hour a day doing
something physical you'll feel better
mentally physically and spiritually
because it's all tied together
in order to fit authentically into 19th
century france and les miserables anne
hathaway lost about 25 pounds to play
the tragically doomed fun team according
to vogue hathaway made her already slim
frame even slimmer by undergoing a
cleanse then spending two weeks
devouring nothing but oatmeal paste the
actress explained that she needed to be
obsessive about the whole experience to
get that near-death look she elaborated
it left me in a state of deprivation
physical and emotional i couldn't react
to the chaos of the world without being
overwhelmed it took me weeks till i felt
like myself again hathaway told people
magazine that it was definitely an
unhealthy amount of weight to lose in a
short space of time admitting i didn't
know anything about nutrition i taxed my
body and my brain bore the brunt of it
for a while i just felt very anxious and
very lost at that time this wasn't the
first time hathaway suffered for the
sake of her art for her role as catwoman
in the dark knight rises she dieted and
worked out extensively she admitted to
elora that her efforts to fit into the
cat suit dominated her life for a year
explaining i didn't understand how you
could be thin and strong i went into the
gym for 10 months and i didn't come out
as a despairing cocaine addict and the
partner of an unpredictable and
hot-headed gangster elvira hancock from
brian depalma's scarface has the sort of
energy that's eating her alive from the
inside out naturally actress michelle
pfeiffer wanted to embody the tragic
heroine in all her raging authenticity
and that involved shedding some pounds
people reports that pfeiffer lived on a
diet of marlboros and tomato soup to
play the love interest of the
larger-than-life tony montana pfeiffer
said i was playing a cocaine addict so
that was part of the physicality of the
park as production continued pfeiffer
became thinner and more emaciated the
actress recalled that what was
originally planned as a three-month
movie shoot ended up dragging along for
twice that time elaborating i was
starving by the end of it because the
one scene that was the end of the film
where i needed to be my thinnest it was
pushed to the next week and then it was
the next week and then it was the next
week i literally had members of the crew
bringing me bagels because they were all
worried about me and how thin i was
getting
when lily collins lost weight to play a
young woman with anorexia in the netflix
movie to the bone it was a harrowing
experience the actress had suffered from
eating disorders in the past and
although she had a doctor on board to
ensure she lost weight safely it was
still a difficult process fought with
anxiety the actress explained to al how
apprehensive she was about stepping back
into shoes that contained nothing but
negative experiences for her colin said
you're doing it for a part but it's
something so close to you there's a fine
line between are you going to fall back
into it are you not
collins insisted that playing the role
for the greater purpose of highlighting
the condition gave her strength and
inner resolve she explained to glamour
that she lost 20 pounds under the
watchful eye of a nutritionist who gave
her lots of supplements she elaborated
we really made sure to maintain a
semblance of control over the situation
and also just to make sure my body was
functioning the way that it should i was
reminding myself daily that i was hired
as an actor not because of the body i
would have attained by suffering
playing an emaciated aids patient isn't
really possible unless you look the part
and matthew mcconaughey certainly put in
a strong effort when it came to losing
weight for the role of ron woodruff in
dallas buyer's club the actor followed a
very unique diet during his preparation
for the project
what were you eating honestly five
ounces of fish cup of vegetables twice a
day
some pudding in the morning and as much
red wine as i liked at night
the actor told the independent about the
effects of his weight loss saying i got
down to 143 pounds and i was always
hungry and irritable my body resembled a
baby bird with its mouth open crying
feed me feed me and you realize mama
bird ain't going to feed you it's hard
mcconaughey wasn't alone in his dieting
health for dallas buyers club to play
the role of a transgender aids patient
named rayon his co-star jared leto lost
40 pounds when asked by the rap how he
did it leto simply replied i stopped
eating it wasn't an easy thing to do
losing that much weight changes the way
you walk the way you sit the way you
think
traditionally the joker has never been a
partly villain his trusted mind and
psychotic personality move fast and
without any excess baggage the caped
crusaders nemesis has never been meaner
or leaner than in 2019's joker and it's
all thanks to joaquin phoenix's mental
and physical transformation into one of
dc comics greatest characters phoenix's
unique take on the tragic clown is more
nihilistic more insane more sinister and
more human than any other version the
joker's wired and angular personality
his uncontrollable tics and his nervous
energy are all captured in phoenix's
oscar-winning performance before he
could film it though he had to shed 52
pounds for the role phoenix believes the
weight loss enhanced his performance but
admitted to the new york times it's a
horrible way to live warner brothers
production notes state that phoenix
achieved that starved and unhealthy look
by eating little more than an apple a
day which didn't make him feel great at
first in the beginning
you're exhausted
i mean sometimes you look at a flight of
stairs and it takes like 30 seconds you
have to talk yourself into it
by the end of the extreme diet however
he was feeling quote energized and
excited still the process took a toll on
his mind he explained at the venice film
festival it turns out that affects your
psychology you start to go mad how
fitting for the clown prince of crime
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you